hey youtubers is charlie hopefully you
guys enjoyed that new flash season 2
footage from yesterday so kind of
continuing with the DC theme I thought
we do some batman v superman and suicide
squad today a lot of you've been asking
you about the Suicide Squad Joker Theory
I've kind of explained it before but
i'll explain why i think it's bogus at
the end of this really i wanted to talk
about General Zod because Michael
Shannon was talking about the movie
Batman V Superman that is I mean he just
confirmed that that is him in the
trailer they didn't use a body double
its not CG he was actually on set
pretending to be dead if you remember in
the trailer it just it looks like Lex
Corp is going to get a hold of his body
and use it to make this green rock or at
least learn what Kryptonians are weak
against we really don't know where the
Kryptonite comes from but we can guess
that it probably has something to do
with the terraformers from Man of Steel
you know the funny thing is is even
though this all seems really planned out
and there's this clear roadmap to
Justice League whenever they started
working on man of steel they hadn't
thought about it that way they were just
intending to make a new Superman
franchise it was going to be
self-contained they were going to cross
it over with batman or anything like
that but i think given the success of
Avengers and the the shared universe it
kind of opened Warner Brothers minds
they said okay you know what we'll give
it a try so Batman V Superman is
probably like part of the pitch that
came from zack snyder after warner
brothers went to him and said hey we're
thinking about doing this movie with
batman in it what you know do you have
any ideas so they're spinning all these
movies logically out of the previous
ones so like in the wake of what
happened in Man of Steel between Zod and
superman batman v superman picks up and
continues the thread so big alien battle
kills a bunch of people does billions of
dollars in damage what do the Earthlings
do the Senate gets involved and then
people like Lex Luthor who are a little
more paranoid little crazier get their
hands on it and say okay you know we're
gonna do something about these aliens
we're gonna get rid of them just because
it's jesse eisenberg everyone's thinking
like evil Mark Zuckerberg because Lex
Corp is going to be a tech giant in this
movie but really he's more of like a
crazy version of Elon Musk and Mark
Cuban I guess you could throw facebook
in there I'm sure social media will play
a role in what's going on in this
universe because it is supposed to be
present day so they're gonna be a bunch
of YouTube clips of Superman fighting
Zod that just like random citizens
uploaded really i don't i don't think of
Mark Zuckerberg is a billionaire
industrialist tech giant
there any billionaire mad scientists in
the real world i would say Elon Musk is
the closest to that I don't think of him
as evil though but I just I like the
idea just because he's making apple
jealous with his Tesla business they're
actually making an apple car now because
of what Tesla is doing so Michael
Shannon just doing regular interviews
talked a little bit about Batman V
Superman on this set but he said one of
the weirdest things ever they just like
stopped me dead in my tracks he said
that he got stuck in a porta potty
because his hands were fixed with
flippers he's like I have flipper hands
in the movie and that almost made me
fall out of my chair I was like okay
wait a minute what what the hell is he
talking about flipper hands how the hell
do you get from fight with Superman to
flip her hands so first off we just have
to acknowledge is there just like so
much going on and I comment1 how did he
get into the porta potty with flipper
hands and how did he get his Kryptonian
suit off if he couldn't work the zippers
Ben Affleck actually ran into Christian
Bale after Ben Affleck had been named
his Batman it was just some random
runnin when they were out with their
families Ben Affleck said that Christian
Bale told him make sure that you can
piss in this suit because it is a
to get off so already your mind is
spinning about how I got locked in this
porta potty but someone let him out Zack
Snyder stop yelling he's like where's
Michael Shannon where the hell is he but
let's think about these flipper hands
and green glowing rocks what I think is
going on is I think they just put
prosthetics on his fingers just to keep
him from wiggling around too much just
just to keep him from because he's
supposed to be dead they're not going to
bring him back to life he's got to be
sitting on a research table while people
poke him and try to figure out what he's
weak against so Lex Luthor probably
found some alien soil samples in all the
rubble left from the terraformers so
he's probably experimenting on that and
probably finds out that when he gets
close to Zod that his body starts to
break down a little bit the thing about
kryptonite though is that it's actually
irradiated pieces of Krypton it's not
just like regular earth rocks from
Krypton so he probably just like slowly
gets to that point as he's experimenting
with Zod's body so hopefully that
clarifies that a little bit I just I saw
a couple people wandering there like is
he gonna get spliced with like Atlantean
DNA is gonna be like Atlantean hybrids
odd no I do not think that that's going
to happen there are a lot of people
wondering if there's going to be a
version of doomsday in the movie because
I mean you have to have like the big big
bad i mean Batman and Superman are going
to be fighting Wonder Woman's going to
caught in the middle so there'll be each
other's villains for like the first part
of the movie but there has to be a real
villain like someone for Superman and
Batman to punch together that could be
something that comes out of lexcorp's
lab but the weird thing about these like
Batman V Superman universe movies is is
they're trying to make them as close to
real life as possible like like if an
alien came from outer space how would
the world react so I'm not expecting too
many fantastical comic booky things Zack
Snyder actually said that when they
wrote the script they just they went
into a room and came up with it on their
own he's a big fan of Frank Miller's but
the story of Batman V Superman has
absolutely nothing to do with the dark
knight returns maybe a couple of visual
Easter eggs like that's about it so if
you saw people going crazy about flipper
hands out on social this morning don't
don't worry but people are still talking
about the Suicide Squad you know Joker
jason todd rumor so i'm going to clarify
that just a little bit like what the
actual rumor is why people think it's a
thing and why I think it's bogus I'll
start off by saying that it is totally
awesome to come up with theories like
this fan theories are what makes talking
about movies fun just as long as you
remember that it's a crackpot theory
that's just fun to play around with it
is just meant to be fun so if you're not
familiar with Jason Todd he is the
person that became robin after Dick
Grayson became Nightwing after he went
off to Teen Titans a long long long time
ago now Jason Todd was not a super
popular character so his time is Robin
was really short in because comics
started to get really hardcore they
wanted to introduce a new Robin so
they're like okay let's do the most
hardcore thing ever we'll kill Jason
Todd so it became this big Joker story
about how the Joker tortured and killed
him and then way way later in the comics
because you know Batman had started to
get boring as a comic they're like okay
let's make this interesting let's bring
back a big villain that is someone from
Batman's past someone who used to be
really close to him that blames him for
what happened so they introduced the Red
Hood character and it turned out that it
was Jason Todd who was not dead he had
been resurrected he went on to become
this crazy antihero that is kind of a
good character but kind of not if you
think that Wolverine is chaotic good
think of red hood as being even more
chaotic good but when he first came
along like he really wanted to kick the
out of Batman
so Jason Todd as a story device is the
character that you bring out when Batman
is riding high and you want to tear him
down in the problem with Jason Todd and
the movie universe right now is that
when we see Batman in the trailer he is
already at his lowest point he's been
retired for a while he hasn't worn the
cape and cowl in a long time he's still
haunted by what happened to this Robin
we're not really sure which version of
robin this is going to be and to bring
in Jason Todd this soon would really
undermine that arc because we're
supposed to get to justice league so
arguably Batman is going to find some
sort of redemption between now and the
end of Batman V Superman so if we do see
Jason Todd in the movie universe or like
a version of him then we probably won't
see him till the new Batman trilogy it
is just they've already announced the
first Batman solo film that Ben Affleck
is going to actually co-write indirect
it'll probably end up turning it to a
new trilogy depending on how things go
and how long Ben Affleck wants to stay
with the role but the reason that people
think that Jared Leto's Joker might be
Jason Todd is is because of the tattoos
like he has you know he has a bunch of
tattoos on him he has a tattoo of a
Robin that we've seen in promo art and
in the video game Arkham Knight ended up
using the jason todd character who also
had some tattoos that were similar but
here's the problem with that here's the
reason that that evidence doesn't stack
up because the video games are not canon
to the movies there are two completely
different teams they have nothing to do
with each other like the people that
make the games they watch the movies
like they listen to the news but they
don't base their game story on what's
going on in the movies or in the comics
they just take a group of characters and
try to tell an interesting story with
them and in and obviously the Arkham
games kind of provide their own
continuity like they're all they're all
connected all the way from Arkham Asylum
to Arkham Knight it's kind of like a
trilogy people also saw the Suicide
Squad trailer and they saw this person
on joker's table and they're like ooh
maybe we're gonna see Jason Todd that's
actually Harley Quinn we're gonna see
the Harley Quinn origin in the movie
she's the one lying there when he's
saying i'm not going to kill you I'm
just gonna hurt you real real bad so
that doesn't mean that will never see
Jason Todd in the movie universe I mean
the jason todd storyline is super super
dark and the movies are trying to be
super super dark so thematically it
would work but I mean Batman really has
to like get his first Redemption before
you tear him back
again like he can't be completely
depressing the entire time he has to
have a couple big victories jason todd
is the character that you roll out after
Batman's had a couple big victories the
world thinks of him in a really positive
way so Jason Hawk comes out and goes
look what you've done you know look what
the consequences are of your actions but
you guys can let me know you know what
do you think about this Jason Todd
theory do you think that it's bogus just
remember that most of the evidence
people are using to support it is based
on the Arkham video game series which i
think is already like a giant red flag
that the people are trying to connect
the video games to the movies but that's
just been my experience in the past and
for people wondering about the arkham
game franchise the game company is
probably going to be making a new
Superman franchise just get really hype
about a super dark Superman video game
trilogy coming but that remains to be
seen they haven't officially announced
it yet just because like a whole bunch
of stuff happened you know bunch of
flash footage Batman V Superman stuff
happening this week if you guys want me
to do like at like a DC Q&A just let me
know and let me know you want the Q&A to
be about just so I know which questions
to pick also coming up this Sunday
feared the walking dead starts I will do
a bonus video before what I'm going to
do weekly videos so just look out for
that the Vixen cartoon is premiering
next tuesday on CW seed I'll also be
doing weekly bonus videos for that too
I'll just I'll remind everyone before it
airs i already know i'm going to be
doing a walking dead giveaway i'll
probably do some kind of giveaway for
the Vixen premiere too so be sure to
subscribe so you guys don't miss any of
that stuff so why you guys wait for that
set to post you can click here to watch
that flash footage that posted yesterday
it's just like a really short clip so
we'll get a longer one pretty soon and
you can click here to learn all about
the captain america civil war footage
from d23 thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tomorrow